Yeah.
And I think like I still have,
have you ever heard of what's called like user dreams?
No.
Where like I think I've fucked up and I was smoking weed again and then I wake
up and I'm like,
oh my God,
how am I going to stop?
Cause I love,
I love smoking so much.
You know,
or whatever your vice was,
you know,
if it was like whatever was,
yeah,
you're just like,
you wake up and you think you're doing it again and then you realized nom I'm
all good.
I used to have dreams like that where I had to go back to high school.
Really?
I just have dreams for years.
Man.
Did you hate high school and fucking hit me too.
I don't think anyone likes it.
And you're like,
you know,
soon to be a professor fucking doctor or something.
But
well I just had no idea what I wanted to do for a living and I was just like,
being trapped in a classroom constantly was excruciating.
I must've had I,
I mean I probably do have like some crazy form of add.
I don't know.
I've never been diagnosed and never been to a shrink.
But if I did,
I,
I mean I'm sure they'd probably try to put me on something if I tried to tell
him what's going on in my head all the time,
they'd be like,
Jesus,
sit down,
hold on,
take these,
take these whatever you do.
It is bad.
But when I was in highschool,
I fucking hated it and I barely got by.
And then when I got out of high school,
I would have these dreams where I'd wake up in the middle of the night and I
didn't have enough credits to graduate and you have to go back.
And I was sitting there in my bed,
but before I woke up trying to decide whether or not I was just going to fucking
drop out and not graduate from high school,
not have a high school diploma or go back and do another fucking year of hell.
And it was my,
my guts would turn and I'd wake up and Oh my God,
I graduated,
I graduated.
Yeah.
It was the worst I did.
I was the same way,
man.
I just like just barely got by high school.
Did you go to school out here?
Well,
I grew up in like Fontana.
Okay.
Riverside County yet fallen Tuckey shout out to double dose more tie out there.
Yeah.
So people like to fight in Fontana.
People like to fight everywhere.
Um,
now you either fight Beverly fighter,
play football in Fontana?
Yeah.
Oh,
he's on meth.
Yep.
But uh,
yeah,
it was the same way.
Just,
just skated by high school and then I remember I didn't even want to walk.
I fucking hated it so much.
I actually rode my skateboard with my friends that were like much older than me
that I go skateboarding with every day.
And we were skateboarding by the high school is everyone walked and got their
diploma.
That was just,
did you get your diploma?
That yeah,
they sent it to me,
but I mean to,
I didn't want to fucking be there,
go to my graduation and I'm like,
I'm gone.
Yeah.
I'm like,
this is once I got through,
you don't have me anymore.
I can be free.
It took me a while to figure out what the fuck to do next.
Yeah.
I would sit there and they would be like,
so what do you want to do?
Like talk to counselors.
And I was like,
I just want to play drums in a band.
Really?
And they'd be like,
well that's not an option.
Like what college are you going to?
And they would talk to me like,
I was like,
just insane.
Isn't that crazy?
That there's so many bands and there's so many drummers?
Why is that not an option?
Yeah.
It'd be better.
They just said,
well,
you know,
like,
I don't know if they motivated you to actually do what you're passionate about
instead of just being,
well,
well that's not gonna happen.
So what do you want to do?
Fucking people that probably wanted to be drummers and just never got a push and
never,
you know,
never made it through.
But then there's the other argument that if you really want,
you'll find a way.
Yeah.
You,
you got to do it.
I mean,
my dad used to tell me the same thing.
He'd be like,
you gotta have a plan B.
And I'd be like,
well if I have a plan B,
I'm not going to try that hard.
Yeah.
I started thinking in my head and then that's when I just said Nah,
fuck that.
Like I'm,
it's only this,
no matter if I'm rich or poor,
whatever,
whatever the circumstances,
this is what I'm doing.
Like I don't give a fuck with the outcome is
I think that's the right mindset.
Yeah.
I don't think people get by that well.
Like when I was uh,
just starting to do stand up,
there was a lot of guys who had full time jobs and they got degrees and you
know,
they would work their full time job and then they would just do stand up like a
couple nights a week.
They never made it.
Yeah.
Cause the obsessed guys and women,
the people that were just like I,
this is my fucking life.
This is what I do.
I'm going to do this.
Those are the ones that do it.
The no safety net people and the ones that made it.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's gonna fucking happen.
You just have to,
you have to stick with it.
I feel like the people who really stick with it and give it like 110%,
your time will come.
It's w however big or small it is,
something will happen,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
If you figure it out and keep improving and keep learning and learn from your
mistakes and learn from your setbacks and,
and keep trying to push and get better and improve.
If you do,
all those things is as hopeless and helpless as it seems.
If you continue to improve,
you've got to get to a better place.
You've got to get better and one day you'll be undeniable.
And if you don't,
and if you just fall back on that safety net,
you're always gonna wonder.
Yeah.
You're always going to look at Travis Barker goal,
fucking ham on the drums and going,
shit,
that could've been me,
dude.
I almost did it.
I actually at one point in my pops and my pops is awesome,
but,
um,
he's like Vietnam vet and you know,
wrote him a Harley his whole life and he just basically said to me,
he's like,
Yo,
you gotta either got to start paying rent at the house cause you,
you know,
you're not in high school no more or,
and get like a 60 hour a week job,
like a real job or you need to go,
you know,
go fucking play drums but you're not going to do it here in my garage.
So I was like,
okay.
And it was probably the best thing that was ever said to me,
you know,
as harsh as it was or whatever.
And then I had actually caved in and I just told my,
my friend Nola,
I was like,
you know what,
I think I'm just gonna,
I'm going to get this fucking job cause I just somehow got a job.
But mate,
you know,
in a warehouse it was like target warehouse making pretty good money compared to
what I was making at the time.
And,
um,
and he hit me the next day and he's like,
I think you're making a big mistake.
I think you're very fucking talented and think you'll regret this and you can
get this bullshit job any anytime down the line,
come live with me on,
you know,
stay at my house.
You could sleep on the floor,
the couch and let's play in this fucking band and do it.
And I did it,
you know,
I was like a trash man in Laguna beach,
lived in like this studio apartment with a couple other guys and just fucking
took off like I had to like,
I mean there was like humility too,
you know,
there was like playing bar after bar and you know,
but I was eating,
I was eating,
I was,
you know,
I,
I was skateboarding every day and I was living at the beach,
playing in a band with my friends.
So for me,
I had already made it.
Those are the best stories.
Yeah,
they're the best stories.
And I think back even to this day,
I go to the gunas sometimes I'm like,
wow,
that was kind of one of the best moments of my life besides my children being
born like poor no money but like happy as fuck.
Like can't even think of another time I was that happy,
you know?
Yeah.
That's cool.
Well the only pressure is the pressure of trying to succeed.
There's not the pressure of already succeeding in the overwhelming pressure that
you must experience now.
Yeah,
those are great stories man.
The stories of like where you didn't know if it was going to work.
Yeah,
you figured it out and clue those stories.
Right now some kids are listening to those stories right now listening to you
say this and they're like,
fuck man,
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to go forward.
Like who knows how many rock stars you're making right now just saying this.
Cause a lot of them are
teeter tottering like am I going to do it?
Am I not going to do it even,
I mean,
I was at the time,
you know?
And you just have to,
you know,
don't worry about being cool or being fucking rich or having money.
Just be passionate about what you're passionate about and fucking dedicate 100%,
you know?
Yeah.
There's those moments,
man,
when you're first starting out,
anything where it's not sure.
Yeah.
It's not a,
it's not a definite thing.
You were in this weird limbo space like,
man,
am I going to be a loser my whole life?
Like what's going to happen to me?
And those moments,
man,
when you look back and you realize you could acquit,
but you kept going,
you figured it out,
you sucked it up,
you worked your way through it,
you improved.
He kept moving.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's,
that's life,
man.
Yeah.
That's what defines you,
ma'am.
Yeah,
it really does.
I just love those fucking stories.
I can never get enough of them,
man.
The dirty,
grimy,
and then finally you make it story.
Yeah.
Fast.